MICHAEL: Welcome.
Thanks for coming or watching
the livestream or the broadcast
of this Talks at Google event.
Today, we have a treat for you.
We have Eric Liu here.
So Eric Liu, he's the founder
of Citizen University,
the executive director of
Aspen Institute's Citizenship
and American identity program,
a former Clinton administration
official, and a
columnist for CNN.
He actually just came
out with a new book,
which is called "You're More
Powerful Than You Think."
And he's going to tell us a
little bit about his philosophy
on influence and creating
change, and how we can do this
ourselves in the community.
So without further ado, I'm
going to turn it over to Eric.
ERIC LIU: Great.
I'm mic'd up.
I don't need it.
To
MICHAEL: Oh, you're good.
ERIC LIU: Thank you,
Michael, and thank you
all for coming today.
We're going to have a
nice focused conversation,
because we'll get
to have a good--
so I'll keep my remarks
brief at the beginning
here, so that we can get
a really good, not just
Q&A, but just actual
conversation here,
including our folks
joining on the livestream.
So I wanted just to
actually give you a sense--
and I know Michael has
gotten books for those of you
who are here.
This is the book that
I'm here to talk about.
I'll pass this around here.
And it's called
"You're More Powerful
Than You Think, a Citizen's
Guide to Making Change Happen."
And the premise of the book
is, literally the moment
that we are in today,
and not just what
the current occupant of
the White House is doing
and the response that
he's provoked, but just
this age that we
are in right now,
which extends well
beyond the last 100
days to really the last
several years, and not
just within the borders
of the United States
but around the world.
We're in this moment where,
across the left and the right,
whether you're looking at
the Tea Party, Occupy Wall
Street, $15 Now, Black
Lives Matter, the Dreamers,
you have all these bottom up
movements of citizens engaging
in basically wanting
to knock over
entrenched, monopolized,
concentrated power.
And one of the
things that indeed
so marks our time right
now is that folks from very
different points on the
political spectrum, people
who were cheering and
going to Trump rallies
and helped get him elected,
people who were hardcore
involved in the Bernie
Sanders movement,
are part of this
same phenomenon,
even if they might say that
their politics or policy
preferences are
widely divergent.
And so this moment that we're
in is one where it's turbulent.
It's exciting.
But what it really
is, is a moment
that is the natural
consequence, if you're
honest about it, the
natural consequence of four
decades in this country in
which wealth, voice, clout,
and opportunity have
been concentrating
into fewer and fewer hands.
And so the overarching narrative
in American life right now,
that the game is rigged, and
that the system is broken,
is not without basis.
The game increasingly is rigged.
Our public policy preferences
at the national level
are increasingly warped and bent
toward those with the greatest
amount of economic privilege.
Even the last administration,
as much credit as one
might want to give it,
and as a Democrat, I do
want to give it credit,
but 95% of the gains
of the recovery
since 2008, 2009,
have gone to the wealthiest
1% in this country.
And so it is a not
unreasonable think
whether you're a Democrat,
you're a Republican,
whether you live in a
blue state or a red state,
to feel like the
game has been rigged.
What marks this
moment, though, is
that we are in the midst of this
incredible cross-ideological,
cross-sectoral great push back.
And what I wanted to
lay out in this book
is really, what do you do after
you have the primal scream?
What do you do after you
say, "I want to push back.
I'm mad as hell.
I'm not going to
take it anymore?"
And what you do is, you
get literate in power.
You get literate and fluent in
what civic and citizen power
is.
And I just want to take
a moment to unpack what I
mean when I say citizen power.
Because it's a way
of just framing up
some of the ideas and
the strategies that I
lay out in this book.
So when I say "citizen"
in the first place,
and that's both in
my talk here but also
in the nonprofit
that I run, which
is called Citizen University,
I want to make clear.
I'm not talking about
documentation status
under the immigration
and naturalization
laws of the United States.
I'm talking about a deeper,
ethical sense of citizenship,
by which I mean
membership in the body,
being a pro-social
contributor to a community.
To put it very simply,
being a non-sociopath.
And that conception of being
a citizen in this deeper
ethical sense is universal.
It, of course, plays out-- and
in the work we do at Citizen
University-- plays out
here in the United States
in a particular
American context,
which is about whether you
were born here, as I was,
the child of immigrants, or
whether you are brand new here,
every one of us here
is an inheritor,
a steward of a particular
creed and a particular set
of promises that
this country made ,
and frankly has never
yet fully lived up to.
So citizenship in the
context of this country
is about being a pro-social
contributor to the body,
but also a steward of that
particular set of promises.
Power, let me just unpack
what I mean by power.
When I say "power," I mean
quite simply a capacity
to ensure that others do as
you would like them to do.
And that, too many people,
sounds a little bit menacing,
a little bit creepy,
almost, that definition.
But I think if
we're honest, again,
about every dimension
of our lives,
we as humans, as creatures with
will and seeking objectives,
are always trying to get others
to do as we would like them
to do, whether in our family,
or workplace, or neighborhood
relationships, or
national politics.
The question is, when you think
about power in the civic arena,
on questions of public
and common concern, again,
I come back to this
notion of literacy.
Can you read and
can you write power?
Can you read what people think
of in a very colloquial way
as the power structure?
When people say the
power structure,
they say the game
is rigged, they
have a very general
but very fuzzy
sense of a way in which things
are stacked against them.
But I think to be
literate in power means
to understand that there are
different concrete sources
of power in civic life--
money power, people power,
ideas power, social norms power,
the power of state action, the
power of force and violence.
All of these are
sources of power
that then flow through a variety
of conduits throughout society,
whether those are organizations,
networks, narratives,
different conduits.
Some are formal and recognized.
Some are informal movements.
But whatever conduits
they are, when you add up
this notion of
sources and conduits,
that gives you what
you colloquially think
of as the power structure.
And if you want to actually
be able to make change
in civic life in
our times right now,
you've got to be able
and willing to read
that map of power.
But power literacy, as it
is with actual literacy,
is not just about reading.
It's about being
able to write too,
and to write yourself
into the story
and write yourself or rewrite
that map or that array
of sources and
conduits of power.
And so in this book,
I talk about there
being three laws of power
in civic life that are worth
probably just unpacking here
as grist for our conversation.
Law number one--
power concentrates.
That's just the
way of the world.
Power, like almost any resource
in any physical or metaphysical
system, compounds.
And those who have
some tend to get more.
Those who have clout
tend to get more clout.
Those who have visibility and
celebrity tend to get more.
And that is the nature of life
in a complex adaptive system.
And I don't have
to tell people who
work at Google, that is the
nature of life on the network.
Power compounds when the
system is left to itself.
Law number two-- power
justifies itself.
So at every turn,
people and institutions
that are incumbent
holders of power
will spin stories
about why that is
and why that ought
to be that way.
And these stories take
a variety of forms.
They can be dominant
narratives about explanations
of, for instance, why in a
different age and to an extent
still today white supremacy
was a good narrative,
good example of a
narrative in which power
is justifying itself.
To a continuing extent
today, male supremacy
is such a narrative.
Another one that takes the
form of economic explanation
is what you might shorthand
as Trickle Down economics.
Trickle Down
economics is a story,
is a fable that has
relatively, actually,
little to do with fact.
But it is a nice
story about how if you
treat those who have
wealth really nicely
and coddle them in the tax code
and our policy preferences,
their prosperity will leak its
way down to everybody else.
That is a classic instance
of power justifying itself.
So if you take these first
two laws, that power compounds
and power justifies itself,
you get into a pretty grim doom
loop, where fewer
and fewer people get
to hoard and monopolize
more and more of the power
and tell you why they should be
able to grind you down to dust.
What breaks us out
of that doom loop,
at least theoretically,
and at least,
again, in principle in a
country like the United States,
is law number three, which
is that power is infinite.
Here I mean this
very concretely.
I don't mean this in a, "I'm a
Seattle guy coming to the Bay
Area."
I don't mean this in some
kind of new age, new agey way.
I mean it very concretely,
that in civic life,
power, new power
can be generated out
of thin air, where it
did not previously exist.
Unlike a physical ecosystem.
The laws of physics
tell us that if you're
going to get more
heat or energy,
then someone else in this
room has to get less.
Law of thermodynamics.
This is a zero sum system with
a finite amount of energy in it.
And that is a law of physics.
But what I'm talking
about here is not physics.
It is civics.
And in civic life, it is wholly
possible to generate power
where it did not
previously exist
through the simple,
magic act of organizing.
Just inviting one other human
to engage in a common endeavor,
with common purpose, toward
common objectives, where
you have to work out, even
among competing preferences
and priorities, a common set
of strategies and tactics
for going forward,
that work of organizing
generates power where it
did not previously exist.
And this idea that
power is infinite,
I don't mean it in a
Pollyanna way, which
is, I don't mean to say
that anybody at any time
can be as powerful as they want.
I don't mean that
anybody at anytime
can be as wealthy as they want.
Nor do I deny that
there are, in fact,
lots of momentary situations
in politics that are zero sum.
The way we run elections
in the United States
is a zero sum deal.
The first person to get 50%
plus 1 is winner take all.
that's a function of
how we have set up
elections in this country.
And there are plenty
of other situations
where things are zero
sum, but in general,
this broad idea that
power is infinite
is both a matter of
mindset and more deeply
a matter of reminder.
The title of this
book, that you're
more powerful than
you think, is really
meant to say that at
every turn in civic life,
and indeed the Trump presidency
is a pretty good example
of it, most of the
time, most people
are incredibly unwittingly
giving away their power.
They throw it away, either
by not participating
or by directing their
attention in certain ways,
or being unmindful of
the ways in which they
are being manipulated.
And so one of the core
purposes of both this book
and the work we do
at Citizen University
is to catalyze people into
a sense of mindfulness
and awareness of
the ways in which we
are full of inactive,
dormant capacities
to make change in civic life.
And again, I don't
need to say it twice,
because we are
living through a time
where people are
waking up at every turn
in every corner of this country,
realizing it and remembering
it.
One of the things that I've
said in a variety of instances
that I will give
Donald Trump credit for
is that he alone,
as he likes to say,
he alone has been
responsible for, I think,
the greatest surge
of civic engagement
and civic participation
in this country
that we have seen
in half a century.
And that's not just women's
marches, and science marches,
and tax marches.
It's not just those
big, visible moments.
It is just this
incredible burgeoning
of an ecosystem of people
organizing clubs, creating
book groups, creating
civics 101 courses,
creating all kinds
of citizen peer
to peer based ways
to teach each other
and remind each
other of the values
but also teach each other the
skills of being able to make
change in your community.
You think about a
phenomenon like Indivisible,
which, for those of
you who don't know,
began as a 26 page
document that a group
of ex-congressional staffers
published as a Google doc.
And it was an insider's
guide for citizens
about how to apply pressure
on your member of Congress
and make your member of
Congress bend to your will.
And it was a good,
useful insider's guide.
Because it was saying,
don't just flood
the fax lines or email
lines or the phone lines.
Like, do this.
Find this person on the staff.
Show up at this kind of meeting.
Ask for this kind of resolution.
And that guide went super
viral online in social media.
But what's even more remarkable
is that after the document went
super viral, citizens all
around the United States started
saying, you know what?
I'd like to use this as an
excuse to meet my neighbors.
And now over 6,000 chapters in
a completely spontaneous bottom
up way have organized to create
Indivisible the Network, not
just Indivisible the Document.
This was not the
doing of the four
co-authors of that document.
They had no direct hand in
making 6,000 chapters sprout up
around the country.
They are very mindful--
and indeed in
their document they
say explicitly that
this is quite a parallel
to the Tea Party.
Because that was
the last time we
saw something like that happen.
And whether or not your
politics are Tea Party
politics, as a person who works
in promoting and celebrating
bottom up, self organizing,
peer to peer citizen power,
I tip my hat to the
origins of the Tea Party.
Because it was just
the same kind of thing.
At the beginning, groups
of pissed off citizens
deciding that they
were not just going
to sit and yell at the TV,
or yell at their screens,
but they were going
to start organizing.
And they're going to start
organizing through-- back then,
I mean in 2010, old-fashioned
technologies like conference
calls.
1,000 person conference calls.
Facebook and Twitter
weren't even as
powerful mediums then as they
are today for organizing.
And what they were
able to do to activate,
again, not just dormant
outrage but dormant power,
is in many ways the
explicit precursor for what
Indivisible is doing today.
So with these three laws,
that power concentrates,
that power justifies itself,
and that power is infinite,
come three simple
imperatives for action
that I just want
to put on the table
here as a way to tee
up our conversation.
So if power is always
compounding and concentrating
into these monopolistic,
winner take all games,
then our imperative in civic
life is to change the game.
If in the second place power
is always justifying itself,
spinning out new forms of
propaganda and narrative
and just so stories about
why it is the way it is,
then our imperative is
to change the story.
And if in the third
place, most people
forget that power
is in fact infinite
and they stay stuck
in these mindsets
that power is
finite and zero sum
and there's no point in getting
involved because the game is
rigged and I can't do
anything and I'm voiceless,
then our imperative is to
change the equation for them.
And so these three imperatives
of changing the game,
changing the story, and changing
the equation both provide
the architecture for the
back half of this book.
And each one of those
three imperatives
yields a set of strategies
for how you actually do that.
And I think here
in conversation,
I'd like to just talk about
both some concrete instances
of this, but also
hear your stories
and your thoughts
about movements
that you might be
involved in or change
that you'd like to see happen.
But I'll tell you about one,
just a set of concrete examples
to make this a little bit
less conceptual for you, that
illustrate these notions
of changing game, story,
and equation.
So I'm from Washington
state, live in Seattle.
And an example that I would
give you of actually all three,
changing game,
story, and equation,
emerged in the immediate wake
of the Sandy Hook Massacre
in Connecticut.
When that massacre happened, a
group of friends of mine and I,
just citizens of Seattle, none
of us was elected, none of us
held public office,
a group of friends
and I said, "we
gotta do something.
We gotta do something
in our state.
The United States
Congress is bottled up,
but we've got to be able to
do something in our state."
Washington state is
generally a democratic state.
At the time, our legislature
was controlled by Democrats
and the governor was a Democrat.
And so we said OK, we
got some folks together,
we got some people
who were experts,
and we came up with a
proposal for a simple piece
of legislation that
mimicked what had long
been on the floor of the
United States Congress
and had died there, a
proposal to institute
a system of universal background
checks for gun purchases.
A common sense proposal
that is supported
by vast majorities of
American public, Republican
and Democrat, but even
majorities of NRA members.
We thought this is
an easy thing to do
after Sandy Hook, a
responsible thing to do.
And in organizing this
group of citizens,
we actually gave ourselves the
name the Washington Alliance
for Gun Responsibility.
Well, what we learned
in fairly short order
was that what seemed like
a commonsense thing to do,
what seemed like
a fairly easy lift
in a Democratic controlled
state legislature,
was going to run up
against a particular game
that the gun lobby
had been playing.
And their game
was an inside game
of politics in which they
weren't really trying
to appeal to a broader public.
They were simply thinking
about finding three, four, five
members of the
legislature, Democrats who
represented swing districts.
And if they could apply
enough pressure on them
to control those members,
they could bottle anything up
and keep any proposal
from actually ever getting
to the floor of the legislature.
And indeed, the NRA has been
super successful in playing
this inside game
in the Legislature
and they were successful
in this particular case.
They kept this proposal
from ever getting a hearing
or getting a vote.
What we had to do as citizen's
then was to change the game.
Fortunately, in our state,
as here in California,
we have a particular set
of tools for doing that,
and that is going to the people.
And so we shifted
gears, shifted games,
and said instead of just
trying to work the legislature
and lobby inside Olympia,
our state capital,
we gotta go out there and start
getting hundreds of thousands
of signatures.
We've got to get a
measure on the ballot
to do the same thing.
And we decided, as a
matter of strategy,
to bypass the inside game
and play an outside game,
go to the public.
And ultimately,
Initiative's 594 passed
and Washington became the
first state in the union
to pass by a vote of the
people universal background
checks for gun purchases.
That story is an instance not
just of changing the game,
but also of changing the story.
Because well, it's actually
embodied in the name
of the organization.
Washington Alliance
for Gun Responsibility
is a name that
makes an argument.
Right The debate around guns
is a debate about gun rights,
and in the words of the
gun lobby, gun control.
It's either gun rights
versus gun control.
And we rejected that framing.
We said, "look, we
respect the fact
that there is a Second
Amendment to the United States
Constitution and that it
guarantees certain rights.
But our view, as citizens, our
view as adults, as grownups,
is that there is no
such thing as rights
without responsibilities,
and that if you
have a worldview that just says
I get to have unfettered rights
and do whatever I have without
regulation, restriction,
or encumbrance,
you're not a citizen.
You're being a toddler."
And so that narrative
shift wasn't just
a matter of framing and spin.
It was a matter of
making a bigger argument
that what we've got to
do as a grownup country
and certainly in the wake
of some like Sandy Hook
is to be able to balance our
rights with responsibilities.
And that narrative was
one that was incredibly
compelling to people
who weren't usually so
receptive to measures
that might restrict or put
some kind of regulation
on the commerce in guns.
NRA members, folks
in law enforcement,
people in more conservative
and rural neighborhoods
began to see the wisdom of
what we were talking about.
I mean, the NRA rank and
file, most gun owners
are really big on
responsibility.
They're really
big on gun safety.
They're really big on
teaching their family
how to and not to
handle firearms.
It's the NRA leadership that
is dogmatic about not allowing
any kind of such reforms.
That's the story.
Well, how do we
change the equation?
We change the equation, not only
by winning in Washington state,
but by setting in
motion now, in states
around the country, this
same kind of process,
where instead of the NRA
just being able to say,
"we're going to play the
inside game in Washington DC
and control the Congress
the way that we controlled,
say, the Washington
State legislature,"
we're now, by encouraging other
jurisdictions in other states
around the United States, to
put measures on the ballot
and go directly to
the people, we're
going to force the gun lobby
to start playing whack-a-mole.
And the NRA is well resourced
to control a single inside game
in the United States Congress.
They're not so well
resourced to play
whack-a-mole in
states and cities
all around the United States.
And that changes the equation
from one in which they
get to dominate and one in
which actually the full breadth
of the people get to be
activated and engaged
in a way that makes their
voice heard and provides
countervailing power.
So I give you that example
just as one way to make
concrete these notions, but I
think all around us right now,
whether it's guns, whether it's
economic inequality and jobs,
whether it's the future
of the gig economy,
and things that are very vivid
here in the tech community,
whether it's housing
affordability and inequality
in places like San
Francisco or Seattle
where I am, on all
these questions,
the fundamental issue in any
issue of civic power is this--
who decides?
Who decides?
And I just want to
close my remarks here
by saying that when
I'm telling you
that you're more powerful than
you think, when I'm giving you
this mental framework for
how to think about power,
when I'm laying out
some of the strategies
for how to exercise power
and change the game,
and change the story,
and change the equation,
it's all about
directing it toward you
being part of the answer of
the question "who decides?"
And I think we're, again, in
this very exciting moment right
now, where lots of folks who
have been on the sidelines,
who have not been
participating at all,
are now starting to realize
that it's not enough just
to be a spectator, that
it is time to learn how
to participate, and
it is time to move
beyond just that primal scream.
We now have the obligation,
those of us who have capital.
Whether in this room
or in this livestream,
you have capital of every kind--
social capital, political
capital, intellectual capital,
relationship capital.
Those of us who have capital
now must choose to circulate it,
must choose now to democratize
our understanding of how
you get stuff done and how
you make change happen.
Because that's the only
way, in the bottom up
and from the middle
out, that we're
going to actually
heal the body politic.
So thank you for
having me here today,
and let's just open it up
for a wider conversation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
again for coming.
So you were referencing the
Seattle and San Francisco
housing markets, which are
particularly difficult,
difficult markets right now.
And as someone that lives in San
Francisco, a lot of what we're
seeing, at least,
I guess the people
that are moving into
the city, they're
what we call the NIMBYs,
the Not In My Backyard,
which are the more selfish
people that have purchased
houses in the past, when the
market was not as competitive,
and have their houses, and due
to the zoning laws in the city,
it's almost impossible.
Because they have a view of the
Bay Bridge or the Golden Gate.
They don't want to
give up that view.
So you have this
voting bloc that's
pretty much blocking any new
apartment buildings from going
in and stuff like that.
I guess the question is,
can you change these people?
Are you able to change them or
is there a certain point where
you just need to give up and
look to Oakland or something
like that?
ERIC LIU: It's a great
question, and it's a question
that San Francisco is
probably the hot embodiment
of in the world right now.
But plenty of other cities
have, to lesser degrees,
the same kinds of questions.
And Seattle is
living it right now.
So I guess I would say this.
Of course it is true that
incumbent power holders, those
who have good views, those
who like the current zoning
system of single family housing
and who might oppose density,
who might oppose
transit-oriented development,
who might oppose changing
the equation, not only
of residents but, again,
of power in the city, they
get the default setting.
The question is whether
enough other folks in a city
can mobilize to shift
the terms of engagement.
And I think the answer
is absolutely yes.
I don't know San
Francisco city politics
as well as I know
Seattle city politics,
but we have a
socialist on the city
council, an avowed socialist,
a woman named Kshama Sawant.
And she was one of the
loud, prime figures driving
the early days of
the $15 Now movement.
And when she got elected, it
was the same election season
during which the
neighboring town of Sea-Tac,
the airport city near Seattle,
also enacted a $15 minimum wage
by vote of the people.
That's a little
town of people who
are immigrants, who work in
the hotel and hospitality
and airport industries, and
who were being ground down
and who voted themselves
a raise, basically.
As that happened, Kshama Sawant
ran this campaign that was also
on $15, but it was
also on this idea of,
we've got to reclaim
a city that is rapidly
becoming San Francisco.
And we've got to actually
start shifting our debates here
on affordable housing.
And so she won.
And her victory, which
was only made possible,
not by a majority of Seattlites,
but by an active, motivated
minority.
Her victory on the
city council completely
changed the frame of
debate in city politics.
It shifted everything leftward.
And I think one of the most
important things-- now, she's
building more of
a bloc, and there
are other folks
in the council now
who have since been elected
who are increasingly
receptive to changes in
zoning, to restrictions
on development to make housing
more affordable in Seattle.
In any city, it begins
in the same way.
We think about
politics as something
that is operating
by majority rule,
but we have to remember
that majority rule is always
a function of minority will.
All it takes is having a
super activated minority.
And so it may seem
that what you're
calling the NIMBYs
in San Francisco
represent the majority of
power or votes or whatever.
But right now, all it takes is
an activated minority of people
to organize and say--
particularly younger people--
to say, "we demand
a different vision,
we demand a different way
of allocating opportunity
in this town, and we're
going to start organizing,
and we're going to start
electing people who
want that same kind of vision."
And I think this is the thing.
The keyword I just
used is "demand."
Frederick Douglass said,
"power concedes nothing
without a demand."
All around Seattle, I've been
seeing these big posters,
giant posters that say
"we deserve rent control."
And I look at that, and
I may be sympathetic,
policy-wise, to proposals
of rent control,
but as has been said in the
classic Western "Unforgiven"
the Clint Eastwood movie,
"deserve" ain't got nothing
to do with it.
It's not a matter of deserve.
It's about "demand."
Simply saying, we
deserve rent control,
that we deserve more
fairness, that we deserve
a city that everybody
can live in,
is nice but completely
insufficient.
Figuring out how you mobilize
people to apply pressure
on your supervisors, to apply
pressure on policy makers,
to apply pressure, again,
of money power, people
power, social norms,
and shaming power
on developers in this
community, to start
pushing for more opportunities
that actually make
it a more affordable place.
I don't think the game
is rigged beyond repair,
but it does involve actually
showing up and being prepared
to make demands that, again,
are literate in the power
grid of your city.
AUDIENCE: OK, for
the next question
we have Russell
from the livestream.
And the question
is, do you think
our current economic
inequality is related
to the decline of labor unions?
And do you think there could be
a replacement institution that
advocates for labor?
ERIC LIU: That's such
a great question.
The answer is yes.
Our economic inequality is
not just correlated with,
it is causally related to
the decline in unionization
in the United States.
And it's a very simple thing to
understand, that capitalism--
we've gone from a
notion of capitalism
that is about prosperity for
all to a notion of capitalism
that is about prosperity
for capitalists.
And that is what
happens when you
have a system in which
there is no countervailing
power to capitalists.
It is in the nature of
capitalism for capitalists
to want to drive
costs down to zero.
Left to itself, capitalism does
drive things and wages down
to subsistence,
near slavery wages.
The only question is whether
you have countervailing power,
institutions have
countervailing power.
Unions used to be that
kind of institution.
And through a variety of
things, a variety of forces,
including, by the way, the
corruption and ossification,
calcification of unions
themselves, they often
have been their
own worst enemies
over the last
several generations.
But I think that's
a secondary factor.
The primary factor
was a concerted effort
in public policy
to break unions,
to make it harder for unions
to organize, to make it harder,
to make it easier for
employees to bypass unions.
So we're at it, again,
that same four decade
stretch that I described
at the outset of worsening
and radical severe income
inequality is a four decade
stretch in which unions
have been ground down.
The second part of the
question, though, I
think is super important.
Because there is no
magic wand today to wave
that's going to turn
our economy back
into a major union economy.
Private sector
unionization rates are 7%.
7%.
So the only place, the
toehold that unions have
is in the public sector.
And quite frankly, in
ways that are problematic,
and that's because employers
in the public sector
are also politicians
who also depend
on contributions from unions.
That's an inherently
messy situation.
In the private sector, the
day in which unions come back
is not going to come.
And so we've got to
start thinking, though,
about new, innovative ways to
generate countervailing worker
power.
There's actually one
that I want to tell you
all about here that's
located here in the Bay Area,
and I happen to serve
on the board of it.
It's called the Workers Lab.
It's based in Oakland.
And the Workers Lab is this--
you could think of
it, essentially,
as a venture capital firm that's
meant to incubate and seed
new ventures in activating
worker voice and work power.
And so it has been
investing in apps
that help people
in the Uber economy
to be able to communicate
with one another.
It's investing in
various other tech
tools that provide a whole lot
more transparency on things
like scheduling in retail.
It's providing other channels
for freelancers and others
in the gig economy
to begin to pool
resources for collective forms
of insurance and so forth.
And they're also just
beginning to seed research
into new forms of what you might
think of as social insurance.
What you realize right now is
that if unions aren't coming
back, and we have an
increasingly gigified economy,
either we're just going to
let people like Uber drivers
or, frankly, contractors to
tech companies like Google,
just be wholly on their own.
Or we are actually
going to agree
that we're all better off
when we're all better off,
and that we together actually
have a responsibility
to create some
network of mutual aid
for people in the gig economy.
My friend David [? Rolf, ?]
who actually does run a union,
he's one of the more creative
young leaders in the labor
movement today.
He runs an SEIU local
in the Northwest
and I write about
him in the book.
David was one of the
co-catalysts of this Workers
Lab, but he's also been
thinking and writing
with some interesting bedfellows
from the business world,
from the reform conservative
movement, from the R
Street Institute
and other places,
getting people from
right and left to say,
"OK, like it or not,
we're in a gigified world.
Let's think about how we create
a system of portable benefits
in which corporations across the
board have to pay in to a pool,
and government maybe supports
and pays into this pool,
but where any employee,
any worker who's
working in a gig economy
knows that she or he carries
with her or him a portable
set of benefits that
don't rely on the employer."
That's a different
way of thinking
about the employer-employee
relationship,
but it recognizes that
in this network age
we've got to come up with
new tools and new formats
for doing this.
That requires some
wonkiness and trying
to figure out just how you
design and structure that.
It's a great question for
people at a place like Google
to be thinking about.
How do you design that?
But before you even get
to the design question,
it requires that fundamental
philosophical commitment
to the idea that countervailing
worker power matters.
And it matters not
just because you don't
want workers to get screwed.
It matters because you want
capitalism not to tip over.
When there is no
countervailing power,
you get what we got in
the financial crisis.
You get just ever more insane
forms of financial engineering
and financialization of an
economy that is unchecked
by these countervailing forces,
and the economy tips over
and it collapses.
But what we've got
to do right now
is to pay attention to
these forms of creativity
and countervailing power.
Thoughts or questions?
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you explained
that it's axiomatic that power
concentrates, right?
ERIC LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think media
is a good example of this.
Six companies control 90%
of the media in America.
So it's very concentrated,
very much an oligarchy.
One thing I thought
that was fascinating
about the past election
cycle, whether you agree
with the outcome or not,
was Trump's use of Twitter
and also the social media to
a countervailing narrative
against mainstream media
was a huge game changer,
I think, and we'll see it
going for election to election.
Could you speak about
technology's role
is decentralization of power
and what more can be done there?
ERIC LIU: That's another great
observation and question.
I mean, candidate Trump is
one of the most important
embodiments of all
three imperatives
I was talking about.
That man knew how to
change the game, the story,
and the equation.
And he knew it intuitively.
He's not-- if you were
to ask him how he did it,
he might not be able to give
you a fully articulate playbook,
but he had a particular
kind of genius
for doing all those things.
And I think the one that
you focus on in particular
is quite at the heart of
it, his sense of how to--
In every phase
change in politics,
the elected leaders
who rise to the top
are those who anticipate
the ways to exploit
new kinds of media.
And that's as true
of a Trump as it
was true for an LBJ, who was
very skillful at exploiting
radio in the '30s and '40s
as he was rising in politics.
It was of course true
of Hitler, but it
was true of politicians-- it
was true of Teddy Roosevelt, who
understood that the arrival
of tabloid newspapers
made it necessary for
someone who was indeed
a very thoughtful,
intellectual person
to basically make
himself into a cartoon,
and to make himself
into this figure
that people could
tabloidize in the best way.
So at any time, our politics
does respond to that.
But your question about how
does technology and media
and the decentralization of
it change the power equation,
I think profoundly.
Look, I mean, all of the
debate and the anguish
about fake news--
fake news is a
consequence of two things.
One is this multi-decade decline
in civic literacy and civic
education, where people
don't know their own minds
and they don't know how
to seek out knowledge.
And so people, we
the people, are
super susceptible to fake news.
But there's always
been fake news.
Fake news is like a virus
that is in the body,
but it only actually
takes over the body
when your immune system
is super compromised.
We've been super
compromised because
of that civic illiteracy.
That's force number one.
But force number two
is the one that you
put your finger on, which is,
hey, everybody's a publisher.
Everybody's a media outlet.
We've leveled completely
between Infowars and CNN
and between Breitbart
and The New York Times.
And so there's just this
flattening, in a way.
Much less individual
bloggers and people
who've built giant followings
just on social media.
I actually think, quite
frankly, the net of that
is harmful to democracy.
All the ways in which hierarchy
flattening media technologies
were meant to democratize and
revitalize democracy I think
have been swamped
and subsumed by all
the corrosive and corrupt
ways in which that very same
flattening has allowed certain
kinds of viruses to take hold
and to spread.
What's the remedy?
I actually I think
the remedy is one
that is a hybrid of the most
old fashioned and the most
newfangled.
I think we as people, as
citizens in that broadest
sense, really have to relearn
how to see each other again.
We have to relearn
the face to face.
And I think our
democracy is only
going to get revitalized by
people recommitting to the face
to face.
However, social
media and technology
can be activated and
deployed in service of that.
It can supplement it.
It can provide--
again, Indivisible
is a great example of this.
Pre-internet, Indivisible
would've been a nice thing--
I actually write about a thing.
In 1969, a group of 12 women
who were really ticked off
about the way that the health
care system was so oriented
around the male body, around
the male standard and everything
else like that, they
wrote this 69 page
document about proposing
ways that the medical system
and the health care system be
paying more attention to women.
They photocopied.
It became this guerrilla thing.
It spread over the
years in this way.
It ultimately became
this famous book
called "Our Bodies, Ourselves."
But it took them months
and years for that thing,
literally, to get photocopied,
mailed, stapled, and spread.
Indivisible- bam.
Overnight, literally.
But the beautiful
thing about Indivisible
is not the way in which
the document spread.
It's the way in which the
document became the inspiration
and the catalyst
for people in places
to say, "I'd like
to see my neighbors.
I'd like to meet people face
to face and talk about this.
I'd like to be able to feel
what it's like in a room
to sense if you're with me or
not with me, to feel if you're
starting to cross your arms and
give me body language about,
I don't like where
you're going with that."
These kinds of things
about the theater
of being citizens
together in a democracy
is what we've got to revive.
And so I'm not being a Luddite.
I'm not saying "turn off your
devices, turn off your screens
and just reconvene
in the town hall."
I'm saying, let's think
about how we activate Google.
Let's think about
how all the folks
here in the civic side of
Google, who are developing
all kinds of cool tools,
and cards, and apps
that you can use in
mobile for voting
and for understanding where
your district is, let's use
those same kinds
of smarts to help
activate the ability of
people to see each other again
and to organize
themselves again.
The simple watchword that I
have for this moment right now,
this is a time when people
are saying, "what do we do?
What do we do?
I went to the march.
What do I do?"
And my answer is very
simply, be like Ben.
By which I mean,
Benjamin Franklin.
Benjamin Franklin was this
addicted, nonstop, inveterate
club maker.
Stamp collecting clubs,
philosophical clubs,
artisan groups,
debate societies,
the first public library,
the first fire department.
The guy couldn't
help but make clubs.
Either make a club
or join a club,
but reconnect with people
in a face to face way.
And then think about how we can
deploy decentralized technology
to accelerate that.
If some of those
clubs are about,
"hey, let's have a fact club.
Let's have a news club.
Let's talk about--"
That's the way in which,
again, from the bottom
up and the inside out,
we're going to
revitalize democracy.
Got another question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, mine's
a follow-up to that
about the technology aspect.
And specifically with the
Indivisibles movement,
I thought that the Google doc
was a great way of finding out
how to contact people.
The challenging thing
for me is, the best
way to contact a lot of
these local congressmen
and even at the senator level
was calling a landline phone,
sending a letter,
writing an email.
From an operations and
technology perspective,
it just seemed very antiquated.
ERIC LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I
was wondering, do
you think this is where a
third party needs to step in
and really introduce
that medium?
Maybe there's strategic
advantage at least
in keeping the status quo
for the politicians, where
you could easily
drown out like that.
Or even in a town hall,
there's some selective bias
in the people that
show up and talk,
and you can control the
access to the town hall.
What do you see is as
the next steps here?
Is it something that
will fix itself,
or does it actively need other
people stepping in to help it?
ERIC LIU: So it's another
great observation and question.
Let me be really clear--
nothing fixes itself.
Indeed, systems left
to themselves, again,
things concentrate, things
tip over, things die.
A prior book of mine is called
"the Gardens of Democracy,"
and it's just to that point
about complex adaptive systems,
when left to themselves,
tend towards these situations
of concentration, and that
to be a gardener means
to weed, and seed, and
feed, and recirculate.
But your specific
question, I think, yeah,
the actions that Indivisible's
asking you to do,
do feel antiquated,
the modes of engaging
with Congress if you
go to a town meeting,
or a public meeting.
And not just Congress.
If you go to your city council,
if you go to your town meeting,
if you go to your library board,
or your utilities commission,
they are incredibly antiquated.
And I think there is
actually a great opportunity
for innovation there right now.
Citizen University,
my organization,
is going to be working with
the Pepperdine School of Public
Policy in LA actually on a
project that we're calling
Reinventing the Public Meeting.
Public meetings are torture.
You go.
You sit in a room
for a long time.
You wait your turn
to stand at the mic,
and you get two minutes maximum,
while the members of the body
sit there, and they're not
really listening to you.
They're doing their other work.
It's just for show,
and then it's over.
Sometimes, if enough
angry people come,
they storm and they
flood that meeting.
And they hold the mic for
more than two minutes,
but it's still this totally
suboptimal way of engaging.
I think this is a great question
for us together right now.
People who care
about civics, people
who care about tech, people
who care about power,
how do we redesign
the public meeting?
How do we redesign forms
of public engagement?
How do we hold
different elected folks
to account in different ways?
That said, I do
want to underscore
that certain old fashioned
things are necessary.
Another movement that
is really interesting
right now is #peoplepower,
which grew out of the fact
that, post-inauguration, or
actually indeed post-election,
the ACLU received this
unbelievable deluge, which
is still continuing, a deluge
of money, and volunteers,
and people saying "I
want to support you.
I want to help you."
And the ACLU, I mean, this
is a great problem to have,
but it was a problem.
Because the ACLU is
structured really
as an organization where
people in different cities
and their ACLU chapters,
mainly they're lawyers.
They're lawyers litigating cases
or making policy proposals.
They weren't really set up
to be a grassroots army.
And so now that millions of
people were coming at them
and saying "I want
to join the ACLU.
What can I do besides
write a check?"
they decided, "we'd better
make a grassroots army."
And so they hired folks
to actually organize this.
And in the last
few months, they've
launched this
campaign, basically,
with the hashtag peoplepower.
They catalyzed it,
but it's, again,
people in localities
running with it.
And I just spoke this
weekend at ACLU People Power
gathering in Washington DC.
And to your question,
they were not
just talking about Congress.
They were talking,
actually, quite specifically
about what can we as
citizens do to make sure
that DC City government does
all that it can and should
be doing to protect
immigrants and refugees?
And there is a
concrete list of things
that DC government
can and should do.
Pass this particular ordinance,
fully fund this project,
make this commitment
on sanctuary cities.
Do this list of things.
And a few things
that, even those it's
a progressive city government,
the government hadn't yet done.
And so it was super useful for
the ACLU to gather these folks.
It was a really great
intergenerational group
of people who were activists
in the '60s and then people who
were 20 somethings and Bernie
folks as well as OFA people,
all coming together to say,
"OK, how do we apply pressure
on the power structure
of DC City government?"
That's old fashioned, still.
You still gotta go
and work the org chart
of DC City government.
You can't just say, "I wish
I could make that go away.
I wish we could make it
obsolete with a new app
or something like that."
That still is there,
and it behooves
us to be able to
engage that system.
But the more of us
who are tech literate
choose to engage that
way, the more that system
is going to eventually
adapt and respond.
The last thing I'll
say, because this
was a note in your
question there,
is it going to
take a third party?
This goes to what
you were saying too.
We already have a third.
We already have a fourth.
The Trump movement is not
a Republican movement.
The Sanders movement is not
a Democratic Party movement.
They each have been fit
uncomfortably into those boxes,
but technology and this
moment of the great pushback
are yielding already
new kinds of movements
that don't fit in the
boxes of our party duopoly.
And I think that's only
going to accelerate.
And again, one of
the things that I
think folks who have a sense
of technology and the fluency
that you have in using these
tools to both bring people
together, to educate people, and
to stir people to action is--
I would close by
extending this invitation
to you, which is, invite people
to use their imagination.
It's literally where
we've got to think
outside the box or
the boxes that are
called R and D, red and blue.
There is a wide open field of
new ways for us to engage here.
And some will be something
like a people's party.
Some will be short lived
movements that arise for a bit
but then shape and push one
of the established parties.
Who knows?
I mean, had Donald
Trump lost the election,
the Republican Party probably
would have shattered right now.
We'd be talking about the
remnants of the Republican
Party, and how there would be
a nationalist party over here,
and a capitalist
party over here.
And there would be a
traditionalist party over here.
All of those clusters
of want and all
of these clusters of identity
are still in the ecosystem.
How can we exercise
our imagination
to give them fuller expression?
That's part of our opportunity
and part of the invitation
that I'd extend to all
of you here at Google
in this moment as citizens.
MICHAEL: With, that let's thank
Eric for coming here today
to join us.
ERIC LIU: Well, thank
you for having me here.
This has really been great.
[APPLAUSE]